[MUSIC]
One of the things that people often
do is they'll create a DevOps team.
So suddenly you have a DevOps engineer,
or multiple.
And they're like.
What do we do?
Well I read in the in-flight magazine,
that we need to do the Dev Ops.
So I went out and
I hired to DevOps team.
They're going to solve
our DevOps problems.
And that team shows up.
And the rest of the organization
knows where the pain is.
They know how they can how
it came to be in many cases.
And they have ideas about where
they want to try to create value.
And then suddenly someone shows up and
they're preordained.
You're the Neo.
You're the one.
You're going to be here,
you're going to fix it, right?
And that narrative is
a terrible narrative.
So that's the anti-pattern.
Now the language is all of the people
who have been living with the problem
are somehow not suited to solve it.
And for sure, that's a bad message.
Right.
It will create structures that will not
serve to get the value that you want.
So if you find yourself
in that situation.
Where you have completed the class.
You have all these skills.
And then you find yourself in
an organization, where they're like.
Okay little devils bunny.
Go make everything better.
The first thing that you want to
do is you want to speak back to
the organization and say.
That's not a thing I can do,
but here are things I can do.
I can partner with your developers.
I can partner with
your operations teams.
There are skills that we can train.
There our capabilities we can
bring into the organization.
But the first thing I need to know is.
Where does it hurt?
And how can I help?